the hospital foundation works very
closely so the National Employment
Agency jobsplus and to support local
enterprises and the recruitment of
people with a disability
[Music]
thus they were looking for stuff to help
us in the tween universe' and we came
across the services offered by the
ministerial foundation the job needs to
be tailor-made to fit the individuals
abilities they helped me a lot in this
process from interviewing to find the
right candidate for the skill for the
job
so once the individual is chosen for
employment the job coach can guide the
person to employment until the person is
independent they come during the week to
see how they are doing if we need to
help them in something else in training
we are happy to contribute because we
believe that people with special needs
have also skills and they can have the
company favor Mandela all that I tell ya
but the managers of mine Masha Masha
media beep Monday babe
all right of now but that can
respectable expect all-new Marvel
[Music]
we recycle